いや
はじめましてい
僕の名前は
いやが見たいと何ば
この世界の
神になると言われている男でこの世界には
犯罪が増えている僕は一つでも多く犯罪を減らしたい
そのを願っていたある日
僕のまだ
一冊
ノートが降ってきた
あればいい
たまたの僕がず宅に帰っている時だった
突然おそらく
黒いノートが降っていきたい
納刀よく見てみるとノートもしました
提出ノート
開店だ
最初は僕
レオ歌家庭ん
心理髪がそこにはいたっ
紹介しよう
[音楽]
リュークだそしてこれがあって
レッツノートしっかりとゲスノートの使い方が書いて僕はいつをすべての説明を以上に
はものすごい量のてくれーなどになら白い濃度のイメージが広がっていた人の名前が
書いている
リュッ
お前以前にも別のこのノートを使っている奴がいたのか
いいたっ
わははおそらく前の所有者が書いた名前だと思われ
簡単にまとめるとこのノートに
名前を化されたものは
んだった
どれくらいで周だけ力
即死ですね40秒台にかかるよ
えっ何 c 良かった
そのシーンの取りにいっ
書かれたためにがシンジ君このノードを使っ
この世界
変えようと同
人を殺せるノートなどられてしまうと僕自身が
捕まってしまってほしい
そんな割に行かない初めはニュー図面とバックにいるみんなの目を盗んでなるべく多く
の犯罪者
このボトル
なくみたいぞ
砂漠僕があっ
正義だ
打力を早い曲解というわけで別の当店しましたはじめしゃちょーデスノートに名前を
書かれると死んでしまうというものすごい下で主人公が犯罪者公開手配てもうどんどん
こうしてくっていう話なんですよ
それがいいバディは置いといてバレるんじゃないかなと思いまして
ブーブー僕も帰って見てるどんな帰って殺せばてぃ検証していきたいと思います殺すん
だけどね目てもフィクションですクロスってアティエ殺して込ん
ん
[音楽]
この a 2版
2人の刑事がいる左の出ると右の子るー
榴弾したらすぐ捕まってしまう
簡単に this ノートに名前を書くが難しいとありありと思えばいい
船津いうのも喉のターゲットたちも隙をついて
リュックからノートってたぞちなみに右にいる人は俺は仲間で安心してくれ
グレーですがません
まず彼らのした料理で濃度に犯人の名前を変えていく
すごいです
島村ました
いう展開だっています
[音楽]
が共闘
よし気づかれていないそして中の遊びにニューズに気づく
俺が殺すた奴の名前がすぐにニュースに乗ってみたい
夏刑事たちの反応をうかがうため
今起きたニュースを彼らに伝えてもらうことでした
これで彼らの出方を見ようい
ましたーーー
薬師寺かかっ
ブーバーしからこの状況だ東京
僕が here
あっていない
僕が犯人ということだと覚えもしていない刑事たち
早速二人目を殺していこう
次はんで彼らの後ろでたって
犯人の名前を変えてみることでした
から気づく
どうだ
環境はたーーー
気付いてないような黒の墓ドーニャ早く俺を見つけないとどんどん死者が出たっ
[音楽]
直近フロッグ aki 以下 re here till
過労死やだろ
確かにこれは殺人事件じゃないがこういう事件があるからこそ僕が半後だということが
可能性が低く
ピアノの練習の酒席で死亡などなかなかないだから俺が犯人だという可能性はかなり
低くなった
次は能望陥って
このノートの切れ端に堪忍名前を変えていくだ
直接書くとさすがにバレるなねー
俺は新しい作品にていることでした
ポテトチップスの袋の中でオーナー望ま絵を描いていく
右手左手で交互にポツジップ沿ったれ
あたかも自然に振舞っているがその隙にしっかりと犯人の名前を変える一回
こうすることによって彼らの近くでも自然に犯人を殺すコツっているそうだろう食べて
覚えてこれ
これだと全員開かせる
その品事件を year
またすか
いや何か日本在住で外国人からひき逃げ事件30分ですよねあっはぁ夕方に
ララウイングって異なるまだまでも出す頑張って勝ったりだよね
すっげーみかんの皮にあたりシミをあっあっないよやしなきゃーっ
そしてさらにもうここまでくると何してもバレないんじゃねーとか思ってきたった
僕は
彼ら系図の正面でベースノートに犯人の名前そして4位おくことでした
道であるバレるかバレないか夫はれ9回
ばれずに書いちゃったわー
[音楽]
そろそろあんにんが死んだ子だ
名前が笑ってとって言えばさあそろそろ止めないとこの僕を止めるはいなくなって
しまうぞ刑事さんたちを
だぜっ群馬県で
[音楽]
カフェレーサーのガソリーナ結んだしていたんだっていう
みんな逃げてんのは逃走中で運営
別れなんでそうパーティーちゃれいガソリンスタンドのトイレデー
手配強さに切り水でしょうせ
絶対膝で悪いった
4が4日
ま確かに馬鹿らしい事件だがまだ笑っているということで行ってくれたの同9時半って
いう可能性はまだ低いと思っている
どうだ刑事さんたち
すごく younger ん
西陽菜
もうこいつらバカなんじゃないとか
統計が堂々とデスノートを持っているもこれバレんぞ多分これいけるぞれ
というわけでもういいや直接のとにかくはもうばれんもんだって
モンストしか見てないも
あー早速犯人を書いていく
バレルクッパれない感や多分バレないなバレない外だかいて
ニュース速報に乗り再び
仲間館
ニュースを読むと思いきやう
実は僕
何か馬の名前をノートに書いたんだ思っ
運動部時とか
何マッハ
なぜそんなに大事ですよ
どうぞへ
ません
英語んしたくて足だけじゃんぽせずね死亡してもらった
三島でであっ
身近に類投稿されて今の機内食どうであれこれでもなぜ僕が犯人だと信じてくれない
ああああああ
そうなにまあしましたら壊れそうなったらもういいだろう
ス今度はお前たちの真横でノートに犯人の名前
親友書いてやろう
なら気づかないのかこの刑事たちはう
[音楽]
近所に住んでいた住人がすまん何か分からんけどさっき見ながら手法は身近に2人目の
死亡しましたねこれでも気付かないんだねー
作戦通り位
ブービー育毛いやもう
とにいつ気づくのやばいよ髪に3校
よし注意ぐるっと
あたり入ってキスのかイラクに溺れ死亡
ドラ気づくて気づかな役
もうなんですよね僕なんがっちデー
もういいやもうこの2人の市立が過去もう
まあもバレないよこれ
わかったわかったわかったそういうことかそういうことがわかったかなのだ
源さんの手元にあるノートがヒントだ
th
by いい顔しましたからっていう
どうだ刑事たんかつ
ロー空だ
クラッチだ
10それ
いいかいたのこれ
[音楽]
えっ
うえぴ
4分
鋳鋼品も呼びたい個入りチェーン付きえっ
そのボタン
本物だポカーン yeah めいっカリウセはなるん
[音楽]
お前ん
俺がノートを使ったことを暴けすっ
もう者を出してしまったんです
我 re ああああああ
[音楽]
me
バッハ